[Musique]
j'ai 18 ans j'ai raccroché le téléphone
c'est ma copine qui m'annonce qu'elle me
quittes pour quelqu'un d'autre
tout de suite je commence à ressentir à
l'intérieur de moi espèce de boule de
feu dans le ventre ça brûle ça fait mal
je sais pas ce qui se passe c'est la
première fois que ça m'arrive comme à
bas prix sans moi pourquoi on m'a pas
appris qu est-ce qui risquaient de se
passer dans ce genre de situation ça
fait mal ça fait mal je comprends pas tu
normal j'étais en train de virer vous je
ne sais pas qu'est ce qui se passe
automatiquement je suis seul dans la
maison je me dis mais je vais faire ce
que j'ai tendance à faire d'habitude
quand ça va plus ou moins bien où je
suis contrarié alors de son sous sol
je prends un sac je me décale être
dedans quand mes cartouches
je prends mon fusil chars dérangeant
back sur le cateau et je file à vive
allure jusqu'au bout de la terre chez
mes parents
j'habite sur une femme arrivée au bout
de la terre du mon petit camp qui la
gêne ce talent mais canettes
je prends mon fusil puis chacune des
canettes bine bine bine tire toutes les
canettes en souhaitant que cette brûlure
s'enlève parce que d'habitude ça
fonctionnait
ça marchait pas c'est encore présents
c'était aussi brûlants que celle de
l'été je comprenais pas ce qui se
passait et un moment donné je me suis
retrouvé à genoux
j'avais le canon enfin dans la bouche
lever le doigt sur la gâchette et je me
rappelle comme si c'était hier
je m'étais acheté ou je tire je sais où
je tire pas et au lieu de série sur la
gâchette j'ai pris le fusil des tirs au
bout de mes bras qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là automatiquement
j'ai pensé à mes parents
c'est pas eu à payer pour ça c'est pas
eu à payer pour quelque chose que moi je
suis en train de sentir que je comprends
pas à l'intérieur de moi et est
rapidement je me suis dit aussi ça fait
tellement mal
j'ai tellement l'impression d'avoir été
comme je t'ai d'être rejeté et en même
temps j'ai tellement moi je suis encore
jeune j'ai vraiment besoin de me sentir
aimés puis je me rappelle made in me
sentir aimé peut-être par moi même parce
que jamais moi j'aurais pris le fusil
pour tuer quelqu'un que j'aime
pourquoi je voulais faire ça avec moi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce moment j'ai
rangé mes munitions
j'ai appris le physique j'ai embarqué
sur mon 4 ou jetons à la maison comme le
petit comme si rien n'était sur le coup
ça allait patrouiller ce qui s'était
passé avec le recul je me pose la
question moi se fait-il que j'ai décidé
de tirer le fusil plutôt que de tirer
sur la gâchette
l'ag de meilleures réponses parce
qu'après coup c'est plus facile
d'analyser savez je me suis rendu compte
que ce qui est venu dans un premier
temps c'est une image
c'était l'image de mes parents
deuxièmement ce que je me suis dit en
lien avec quoi mais là je m'en rends
compte maintenant mais j'avais une
valeur importante qui était déjà
installé à l'époque vous fait pas de mal
à ce qu'on aime et c'est toute cette
combinaison là qui a fait en sorte que
le choix que j'ai fait ça s'est passé en
une fraction de seconde étape a analysé
comme je le fais là mais c'est ça qui
s'est passé
quelques mois plus tard en fait j'étais
à la fin d'une session de cgg une
situation qui m'appelle qui marque et
qui m'est fait une belle opportunité qui
m'est donnée d'avoir une première
entrevue d'emploi ce que je travaille
sur la ferme la maison mais ses passes
ont nécessairement que je veux faire
dans la vie alors j'ai une opportunité
de faire première entrevue d'emploi que
je pense du mieux que je peux je n'avais
pas d'expérience en entrevue alors je
fais de mon mieux et c'était pour un
poste d'animateur dans un camp de
personnes handicapées un camp de
vacances pour personnes handicapées
l'été alors j'aurai la maison tout fier
je sais pas si je vais être choisi ou
non
quelques jours après le téléphone sonne
à la maison je prends un téléphone on
m'annonce que j'ai le poste j'ai le
poste yes mon premier boulot mon premier
emploi
et pourtant c'est le même téléphone
physique mais bref j'avais hâte
d'annoncer sans mes parents je me suis
dit je vais attendre super faire ça de
façon solennelle
peut-être tout heureux tout content
alors arrive ou super jeu printemps
n'annoncer mes parents waouh
j'ai eu mon premier boulot je recommence
à travailler cet été génial pendant dix
semaines
et là je m'attendais à une réaction
enthousiaste de mes parents j'ai eu
droit à un silence assez long ça m'a
paru en fait mais ce silence l'a
finalement mon père m'a regardé et m'a
dit bruno combien on paie ah ben je dis
c'est génial parce qu'on paye 250 $ par
semaine
logés nourris ou super mon père du tri
bruno important sur la fin on a besoin
de toi t'es bon puis 13 moi je vais
t'offrir le même salaire 250 noms même
un peu plus je donnais 275 personnes
mais en plus je met un petit peu
d'essence dans le camion
parce que je sais que comme ça fait des
sorties du week-end fait que je vais te
donner ce petit bonus là en même temps
ils ne m'ont pas s'attendre à une
réponse rapide de ma part le silence
était de mon côté
je me sentais tellement déchiré mais
déchiré à l'intérieur parce qu'à la fois
j'avais cette espèce de pousser où
j'étais tellement attiré par ce besoin
d'autonomie soit besoin de réalisation
par rapport à un premier boulot et en
même temps l'autre côté déchiré parce
que je voulais pour lui refaire de
paiement mes parents je voulais pas ça
crée une dispute tout ça crée une
tension donc cette espèce de besoin de
toujours et apprécié des autres alors
j'étais vraiment thiriez comme ça ça a
été le lendemain au souper où j'étais
capable de rendre une décision où je
donnais pas raconter merci pour l'offre
un grand merci mais je vais choisir
quand même le camp d'été parce que c'est
ça que je veux faire de mes parents ont
respecté ce choix ont respecté cette
décision je me suis rendu compte après
coup que dans cette espèce de dualité
comment comment faire comment choisir
c'est quoi la bonne décision
je me suis rendu compte que les émotions
qu'on s'en montre que celle que moi j'ai
ressenti viennent donner une valeur aux
options qui s'offraient nou camp les
options sont apparus c'est comme celle
que j'ai choisie en bout de ligne c'est
est l'option la plus la plus forte
émotionnellement tu le coût pour ça que
j'ai fait comme réflexion c'est après
coup que je suis capable d'analyser ça
il ya une autre situation qui a changé
complètement ma vie est pour ca seront
bien petit pas en arrière
ça a commencé quand j'étais jeune
j'avais huit ans j'avais commencé des
cours de piano
je voudrais flûte à bec à l'école puis
j'avais un professeur qui nous
accompagne au piano et puis bref j'étais
très attiré c'était la première fois
qu'ils étaient en contact avec cet
instrument est finalement mes parents
avaient accepté de me faire suivre des
cours de piano
ça a duré trois ans trois ans plus tard
mon prof de piano a dû m'annoncer
qu'elle quittait le
la municipalité pour des raisons
professionnelles s'était dit soit le
prof de piano à la maison je n'avais pas
de problèmes à la maison bref c'est un
deuil quand même important plusieurs
années plus tard je me surprenais que
des gens me refléter ça je me surprenais
à dire à qui voulait bien l'entendre
vous savez moi un jour je vais avoir un
piano chez moi et moi un jour je vais
avoir un piano chez moi c'est pas rien
dans une diction aujourd'hui ça paraît
bien dans une discussion d'un dîner de
chambre de commerce ou peu importe
mais un jour jean voirin piano chez moi
mais je faisais aucune démarche concrète
pour chercher un cadeau je demandais à
personne connaissez vous quelqu'un etc
mais je faisais pas alors ce qui s'est
produit c'est que quelqu'un de mon
entourage un jour qui m'a dit bruno
quelqu'un dans mon entourage qui cherche
à vendre son piano qu'elle veut pas le
vendre à n'importe qui parce que c'est
important pour elle puis le pommier
petite annonce que cherche quelqu'un de
spécial ma première question était
convié combien le vin le vin ce qu'il
m'a dit c'est qu'elle le vent 2500 $ aux
2500 $ non non je n'achète pas piano au
moins plus que 5 sandra ça m'intéresse
pas bruno voyant ces des années qu une
chauffe les oreilles avec le fait que tu
voulais avoir un piano là dessus
maintenant le voir juste pour le fun
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'en ai pour le
fond j'arrivais chez cette personne là
je me rappellerai toujours j'allais dans
le salon et je vois ce piano là le piano
droit en acajou les notes en ivoire et
le panneau avant sculptait la main c'est
un piano de mark cuban de l'année 1908
je tombe en amour avec ce piano le
saphir war et là je demande à la
personne du côté
moi j'ai perdu ma coordination main
gauche mais droits qu'un depuis les
années alors je demande à la personne
pouvez-vous me me jouer un petit quelque
chose pour problème bruno assieds toi
que je fais ainsi les personnes
commencent à jouer
il s'est passé quelque chose je dirais
de magique à ce moment là c'est parti là
vraiment du fond comme une espèce de
bonne fontaine qui s'ouvre la personne à
commencer un jour je me suis dit bhl
naples a rimé mais pas pleurer comme de
petites gouttes ici mais ça sorte
et quand robinet je pouvais pas
contrôler ce qui se passait tellement
que personne en juin oui ça va ça va
mais bref ça fait tellement du bien
c'était tellement whaou
mais je n'avais jamais vécu ça de toute
ma vie
une fois qu'il a terminée moi je suis
tout mouillé de partout je tremble comme
ça puis dans ma tête je l'épaule de 1500
$ donc je peux pas dire j'achète tout de
suite alors dit je conduis d'habitude je
vais y penser et je parle puis je vais y
pense effectivement que je sois que
j'avais dans ma tête je peux aider petty
soit pas être capable de shooter jeu
prêté capable de bien dormir tu fais de
la pitoune beaucoup d'un côté comme de
l'eau le lendemain matin je me suis
réveillé avec quoi dans la tête
j'avais juste mon piano dans la tête je
sais que mon piano ce n'est pas à moi
quand mais c'est comme ça mon piano
tellement que j'avais des difficultés
organiser ma journée de travail en fin
d'avant midi je prends le téléphone et
jose téléphoné à la personne et je ne
m'en sens qu'on va vendre au piano par
son label je suis acheteur et là je me
met à trembler comme ça je viens de
m'engager dans quelque chose que je sais
que rationnellement que j'ai pas les
yeux super bruno est ce qu'on peut se
voir en fin d'après-midi oui pas de
problème
racheté la personne et la fébrile je lui
explique un peu tout ce qui se passe je
lui explique en même temps que je le
vois comme mon piano mais j'ai pas les
sous je peux pas le pays tout de suite
mais personne ne dit pas problème nous
pousse à le faire rentrer au versement à
super trois versements en même temps je
n'ai pas plus à l'abri mais dans il y
avait quelque chose au fond de moi qui
faisais ça se peut pas que ce piano là
et à quelqu'un d'autre que moi je vais
le payer cash piano ça peut pas faire
autrement tellement je partage tout ça
avec la personne elle m'a dit bruno
vient donc cherché avec toi des ménages
en maintenant le même maison le château
des méthodes que va commencer à jouer un
prix une tour à tour les choses vont
bien aller pour le bien de se passer
c'est ce que j'ai fait effectivement et
le monsieur mis à rejouer les enfants
l'époque j'avais julich été mené juste
de naître à bessines ma petite fille
sarah qu'avait deux ennemis qui me
demandent à tous les soins pas parce que
peugeot ne tienne le petit peu je jouais
mal pour elle c'était bien et tout ça au
fait en sorte que ça a changé vraiment
ma façon et de commencer et de terminer
mes journées et elle manque aujourd'hui
abstrait y avait deux ans et demi et la
vendeuse et cl maintenant qu'il ya le
piano qambar 1908 à la maison chez elle
et l'a pris des cours de piano à
l'époque s'intéressait la musique est
tellement que ma petite fille sarah
l'époque ce que j'ai su plus tard vivait
beaucoup d'intimidation à l'école se
faisait bousculer se faisait pousser se
faisait cracher dessus etc
et dès qu'elle a commencé à suivre ces
cours de piano et s'intéresser à la
musique
ap stick est en train de s'éteindre à
leur l umih et et ça change et ça évite
son côté qu ont redonné confiance en
elle
puis ça lui a permis effectivement de
foncer dans le vip d'atteindre ses
objectifs
je me suis rendu compte en bout de ligne
qu'une émotion pour moi c'est un
marqueur d'importance plus l'émotion est
intense plus la situation est important
même si je la comprends pas c'est ce que
j'ai appris de ça et quand même temps
pour être en contact avec une émotion
mais parfois faut que je faire et aider
un petit peu et dans mon cas c'était la
musique de canal musical qui m'aidaient
juste à être en contact avec nous des
émotions qui parmi vous avais déjà mais
écouter une musique qui vous amène
directement soit à pleurer ou à sourire
on a tous de musique pour faire du
ménage ou etc
mais ça me permettait d'être en contact
avec ce que j'avais besoin de ressentir
quand j'avais besoin d'exprimer
davantage me mettais à jouer même si je
jouais mal nos frites et parce que
c'était une façon d'expression c'est
drôle aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
gens cherchent de plus en plus à un peu
camoufler leurs émotions cachées ou
endormir ou même engourdir leurs
émotions quand fait des rencontres de
groupe chez rock on parle ouvertement
des émotions qu'on
lorsqu'on est dans le milieu des
affaires lorsqu'on parle trop des
émotions qu'on ressent ça peut même nous
nuit et des gens pour qui
dès qu'on commence à ressentir quelque
chose savent pas quoi faire avec
puissance et un peu comme moi quand
j'étais plus jeune je comprends pas ce
qui se passe donc on va prendre un petit
verre du petit verre trop petit va être
les bouteilles parfois ça toi et on va
prendre un petit joint ou de petit joint
ou etc
parfois ça va être docteur avez vous
quelque chose qui me permet de pure
sentiers à grand chose
ou de me ramener un petit peu plus sur
le net au québec on est un des régions
dans fait qu'ils sont les plus grands
consommateurs d'anxiolytiques et
d'antidépresseurs et c'est drôle en
parallèle avec ça on utilise nos réseaux
sociaux
nos téléphones qu'on s'envoie des petits
bonhommes sourire puis des émoticônes
pour essayer d'exprimer nos émotions
mais dès qu'on ressent une réelle
émotion
c'est drôle plusieurs personnes
cherchent à s'en cacher et je le sais
j'étais psychothérapie pendant 18 ans
j'ai rencontré des centaines et des
centaines de gens qui savaient pas ce
qui se passait quand ils ressentent et
une émotion donc essayé de camoufler
quand vous et moi une émotion
ça nous apporte un message même si on ne
comprend pas tout qu'il reste un peu
comme une petite lumière dans le tableau
bord du véhicule des fois et des
affaires qu'on comprend plus ou moins
mais c'est un peu seul message mais si
on cherche à engourdir nos émotions les
camoufler entre vous et moi je pense que
le message est biaisé parce qu'on aurait
pu le même message comme tel on aurait
pu nécessairement la même information
en bout de ligne quelle décision va
prendre par rapport à ça de pris une
décision ce soit en venir ici au fait
vous pensez peut-être que c'est une
décision logique et rationnel peut-être
mais peut-être parce qu'il ya donné le
petit côté de hockey jiva c'est
peut-être le côté ou à fait que je vais
apprendre quelque chose après que je lui
plaisais où il va peut-être passer
quelque chose ou etc
c'est le côté mental émotionnel qui est
venu alimenter votre organisation est un
marqueur d'importance une émotion tout à
fait prendre une décision basée jeu sur
les émotions dont j'ai déjà fait ça mais
je vous
vous que ça arrive moi j'avais
l'impression d'avoir pour beaucoup de
balises
c'est comme si j'étais dans une voiture
avec un gros moteur n'avait pas de
volant donc je savais pas trop où
maintenant aller avec ça quand j'ai pris
des décisions basées uniquement sur la
raison c'est arrivé aussi des raisons
logiques c'est parce que j'avais envie
mais c'était ce qui était le plus
logique c'est comme s'ils étaient dans
la même voiture avec un bon volant mais
pas de moteur
donc je me suis rendu compte que par
rapport à ce que je ressentais si
j'étais en mesure d'aller chercher la
raison au service de l'émotion
là j'avais vraiment l'impression
d'avancer là j'avais vraiment
l'impression que les connais ce genre de
décision d'être vraiment sûrement x ils
n'ont pas d'état côté de la track
on a tous pris des décisions on se
trouve peut-être cassé la gueule
moi j'en ai plein toute une liste de 100
et la plupart du temps où je me suis
cassé la gueule c'était des décisions
qui était prise davantage sur la base de
la raison suivante quand on ressent une
émotion
on va chercher sa faute à qui la faute à
quoi
plutôt que de chercher le réellement le
réel déclencheur à l'intérieur qu'est-ce
qu'il a déclenchée c'est quoi le message
rappelez vous une émotion plus elle est
intense même si on la comprend pas plus
c'est un marqueur d'importance plus ça
signifie qu'il faut s'en occuper et
comprendre davantage ce qui se pense
donc l'émotion et la raison permet
vraiment de faire en sorte que pour moi
c'est pour ça que le coeur et sa raison
alors je
merci
[Applaudissements]